should people be staying at home if they
can or returning to the office
employers need to be carrying out proper
risk assessments and publishing them and
consulting with their unions and their
workforces
about them the question is is what's
safe and I I think what's important is
that the Prime Minister recognizes that
the best way to get people back to work
is to do it safely the best way to drive
up consumer confidence is to know that
we've got a really effective test and
trace system in place so that when we do
get local outbreaks as we've seen in
meatpacking factories and fast fashion
that we deal with it properly and that
people can afford to take time off sick
instead of having to rely on 96 pounds a
week statutory sick pay we need to see a
boost to that and need to make sure that
all workers are covered yeah as you say
you know it's been very clear the
consequences get of getting it wrong in
the workplace when you see what's
happened in Leicester interesting that
you mentioned sick pay on the show last
week Matt Hancock said that the
government's got powers to close down
businesses and post fines if they're not
doing things right and do you think that
a tough enough approach has been taken
on these rogue employers well dirty UCM
unions have long been arguing that it
was the wrong thing to do to cut the
number of inspectors and inspections on
the contrary we needed to boost
inspections but more than that we've
offered that we've got 120,000 trained
and accredited a Union Health and Safety
reps we're happy to let those reps be
used to support our inspectors and my
goodness me Leicester proves why you
know that exploitation is nothing new
we've known about it for years unions
have been arguing let workers have the
right to talk to unions on-site in the
workplace so that we can clamp down on
this disgusting exploitation government
needs to listen another big
part of course of people feeling safe at
work is the measures of their employees
can take over things like face coverings
do you think that there needs to be
effectively an assumption that unless
it's impossible you should be wearing a
face mask at work well the first thing
that employees should be doing is making
sure that workers are socially distanced
and you know the Tomita rule has now
been changed to one meter plus but what
we need to make sure is that where
employers in consultation with their
workforces see that they they need
backup in terms of PPE then that must be
available I think again what's worrying
is that you know we've got lots of good
manufacturing firms who unions and
employers working together we switched
production to PP ventilators and other
necessary health equipment we need to
see a real strategy from the government
to make sure that that's available not
only in NHS and care where it's crucial
but for key workers across the economy
and indeed more broadly across the
economy and what I think we haven't seen
yet is that kind of hard planned from
the government about how we're going to
get back to work
safely because we know that the best way
to deal with this crisis is to grow our
way out to work our way out there's also
reports that the government is looking
at changing the advice on public
transport which is a minute they're
saying only take it if there's no other
method of transport available and do you
think it's a good idea to start getting
more people on the bus and change of
course would help more people go back to
work as well I think the worry is that
the government's being driven by how do
we how do we get people using
restaurants and bars more and to do that
we need people who are currently working
at home to get back into the town
centers that could put real strain on
our transport systems which you know
it's very difficult to a socially
distance on a train or a bus unless
you're controlling number
and you need marshals to do that so it
needs to be planned but as I say the
real challenge now for the government I
think is to make sure that when we do
get those local outbreaks we clamp down
hard and that means that there have to
be has to be an effective test and tray
system in place and we need really you
know the more you relax
lockdown the tougher you have to be on
safety standards at work and on public
transport to make sure that we don't end
up going back to square one with local
outbreaks that then gets out of control
you were saying there about the
government having an eye on getting more
people to any restaurants and shops but
you know if you look at the state the
high streets it's not a good thing when
it comes to jobs you know for example
we're seeing more than 400 redundancies
announced at Boots over a thousand at
Pratt Amon J you know as head of a Tec
shouldn't you be pleased that more
people are going to be getting out there
and supporting the high street we want
more people to buy more goods and
services to drive up consumer demands
and of course one of the best ways to do
that is to drive up wages which is why
we've been calling for millions of key
workers to get a pay rise let's not
forget we've got seven in 10 workers in
the care system on less than 10 pounds
an hour if we really want to build
confidence about spending on the high
street then we have to tackle that
scandal of low pay I'm also quite
interested by reports in the newspapers
this morning that Primark could be set
to reject a 30 million pound treasury
handout that's available for every work
that brings back from furlough do you
think that good employers who can afford
it should be following Promax example
and saving the taxpayer money absolutely
and I think what what we're worried
about is that there's a risk of getting
into the getting into gimmicks rather
than actually giving the targeted
support that industries need I mean you
know that for a long time now the TEC
has been calling for the government to
set up a national recovery council to
get government unions and business
around the table
to figure out how some of our industries
that through no fault of their own
simply because of this crisis are in
real trouble like manufacturing like
aviation like the high street we have to
have targeted plans in support to keep
them on their feet
you know what the autumn will be too
late furlough the Chancellor says is
going to end there we're looking for
flexibility and targeted support to get
us through this top period I'll tell you
it's it's a lot easier to hold on to
good jobs that we have already than to
try and create them later down the line
and the biggest threat we face now is
mass unemployment the costs of that be
known not just to working families in
the economy but in terms of health and
crime all sorts of social problems are
really high so we've got to do
everything we can to hold on to the good
jobs we've got that's the way to rebuild
our economy